thank you
agents as new recruits to the Strategic
Homeland division it is my job to bring
you up to speed with what's happened so
pay attention closely as we don't have
much time
in late November a man-made disease
called the green poison was Unleashed
into Manhattan on one of retail's
busiest days of the year Black Friday
[Music]
by early December New York was brought
to its knees the world watched closely
as the events unfold
ultimately presidential director 51 was
executed and the Agents were activated
to protect civilians and key locations
it wasn't long before reports started
pouring in from first wave agents about
the unimaginable levels of chaos that
they were witnessing
among other missions first wave agents
are tasked with escorting a local
community leader to safety but find
themselves coming to the aid of the
Trinity Church which is under attack by
Raiders
they arrived but we're too late the
group had already left and had taken a
number of key medical personnel with
them as hostages the agents were able to
catch up with the Raiders on Liberty
Island that this came at a cost
they continued to fight the growing
violence in an attempt to restore order
to the city but within days contact with
the entire division team in New York was
lost
in early January a new wave of division
agents in the District of Columbia
Washington DC was activated by the
president food and gas shortages
combined with widespread power outages
created city-wide rioting and looting
high-level government officials are
relocated to secure sites around the
country
after suffering heavy losses on their
way into the area the second wave begins
clearing the Hostile prisons alongside
the jtf
the effects of the dollar flu has now
been felt across the globe as it
continued to spread
late January a unit of the division
agents are sent to a small town in the
middle of the U.S called Silver Creek
their mission was to quickly and quietly
secure and protect a high-value
government seed storage complex in the
city
early February the city of Boston Falls
Massachusetts agents are activated
in Washington DC the situation continued
to get worse the broken chain of command
in the U.S military caused troops to be
thrown into crisis there were desertions
widespread deaths and the uprisings of
hostile factions were starting to get
out of control
early to mid-February first wave agents
who survived the early events of the New
York City outbreak find themselves at
the Manhattan base of operations
they go on to continue their mission of
saving what remains and help in
protecting the new peaceful civilian
settlements that were starting to pop up
throughout the city
is that this time that they also
encounter a new Menace that has been
plaguing the city calling themselves
Freeman
in March Silver Creek's power grid went
offline but was subsequently brought
back up with the help of the Nelson
Botanical Conservatory
by mid-march following a series of riots
Silver Creek City Center is barricaded
to keep future refugees at arm's length
martial law was established in the
Silver Creek militia was formed
by early May Washington DC fall
on top of this the shd network has been
taken down Agents from around the nation
are redirected to DC to restore order
and repair the shd network all apart
from the agents in Silver Creek they are
told to stand their ground as the
government complex is too important to
lose even in the face of disaster in DC
the months between March and late June
is when Rural America began its heavy
downward spiral and this was going
unnoticed as support was being focused
around major centers
chaos erupts people die and no help
comes by late June Silver Creek City
Center is engulfed by a new wave of
riots and refugees
August DC agents receive a distress call
from New York City Lower Manhattan has
been attacked and the man responsible is
someone we've been looking for since the
early days of the outbreak
late August Silver Creek has been taken
over by two warring factions calling
themselves the vultures and the Reapers
vastly outnumbered and unprepared an
agent called in for aid over local shd
frequencies
this has just been a brief Roundup of
events agents as this is all that time
allows command has informed me of a big
Intel drop coming soon so stay alert but
for now you have your placement details
so get out there and give them hell
extremist malice extrema remedia
foreign